>>>.
♪♪
IN OUR NATIONAL SEPTEMBER 11th,
2001, 20 YEARS MARKS THAT SINGLE
DAY THAT HAS CHANGED SO MANY
LIVES FOREVER.
THEN PRESIDENT GEORGE BUSH VOWED
TO DEFEAT EVERY TERRORIST GROUP
OF GLOBAL REACH THAT THEY
CHANGED AIR TRAVEL FOREVER AFTER
19 HIJACKERS TOOK OVER COCKPITS
AND SENT COMMERCIAL PLANES ON
SUICIDE MISSIONS.
AND THAT DAY CHANGED, WELL, SO
MANY FAMILIES, INCLUDING MY NEXT
TWO GUESTS, SECOND LIEUTENANT
HANNAH BOURNE WAS ONLY 3 YEARS
OLD ON 9/11.
HER AND HER SISTER WERE AT
DAYCARE INSIDE THE PENTAGON WHEN
AMERICAN AIRLINES FLIGHT 77
CRASHED INTO THE BUILDING.
HER MOTHER WAS WORKING JUST
ACROSS THE POTOMAC RIVER AT AN
AIR FORCE BASE IN D.C.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT SERVICE AND
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT DAY.
BUT FIRST, I'M A DAD, I CAN'T
EVEN IMAGINE YOUR FEELING FROM
ACROSS THE RIVER AND YOU SEE
THIS EXPLOSION AT THE PENTAGON,
YOUR TWO LITTLE GIRLS ARE THERE.
>> IT'S STILL A VERY RAW
EMOTIONS COME THROUGH AND A LOT
OF MIXED EMOTIONS.
AND YET AT THE SAME TIME WE
TRAIN FOR THAT.
I WAS A LIEUTENANT COLONEL, SO
PRETTY MUCH 18 YEARS OF SERVICE
AND IN THAT TIME FRAME I THOUGHT
ABOUT THREE THINGS.
FIRST WAS WE HAD PEOPLE IN THE
PENTAGON, AND I HAD A FIRST
SERGEANT THAT JUMPED AND WENT
THERE SO HE WAS OUR EYES AND
EARS, CALLED MY HUSBAND AND
SAID, HONEY, THE PENTAGON'S BEEN
HIT.
HE SAID I'M ON MY WAY SO I COULD
TRUST THAT THEY WERE GOING TO BE
HOPEFULLY RESCUED, ALTHOUGH WE
DIDN'T KNOW.
AND THEN, FINALLY, I ACTUALLY
HAD TO DO THE MISSION, WHICH WE
HAD BEEN TRAINING FOR AND NEVER
THOUGHT WE'D HAVE TO.
AND I HAD GREAT YOUNG MEN AND
WOMEN WHO STEPPED UP AND
SURPASSED EXPECTATIONS.
BUT, YES, IT WAS MIND-RACING AND
LOTS OF EMOTIONS AND MIXED
EMOTIONS ON THAT DAY.
>> AND THANKFULLY BOTH OF YOUR
DAUGHTERS WERE OKAY.
LIEUTENANT, DO YOU REMEMBER
ANYTHING FROM THAT DAY?
YOU WERE 3.
>> I WAS YOUNG SO MOST OF MY
MEMORIES ARE A BIT FRAGMENTED
WHERE I HAVE BITS AND PIECES
THAT ARE REALLY VIVID.
AND OTHERS THAT ARE MAYBE A BIT
BLURRY IN MY TIME LAPSE.
BUT I THINK THE COMMON THEME
ACROSS MOST OF MY MEMORIES IS
JUST OVERWHELMING CONFUSION AS I
STRUGGLED TO PROCESS WHAT WAS
HAPPENING.
AND ON TOP OF THAT JUST SENSORY
OVERLOAD WITH THE SIGHTS AND
SOUNDS AND SMELLS OF THE DAY.
BUT I THINK REGARDLESS OF HOW
YOUNG YOU WERE THEN OR HOW MANY
YEARS HAVE PASSED WHEN YOU HAVE
A SENSORY EXPERIENCE LIKE THAT,
IT'S A MEMORY THAT NEVER LEAVES
YOU.
>> YEAH, I CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE,
CONFUSING FOR ANYBODY, MUCH LESS
A 3-YEAR-OLD.
SO, A FEW DAYS AFTER YOUR
HUSBAND WHO'S ALSO A GENERAL, WE
SHOULD POINT OUT, WENT ON HIS
FRANTIC SEARCH, FOUND YOUR
DAUGHTERS.
HE WENT BACK TO THE DAYCARE TO
THANK WORKERS AND TO ASK THEM
HOW THEY WERE ABLE TO MOVE SO
MANY OF THESE YOUNG KIDS AND THE
CONFUSION, SOME OF THEM WERE IN
CRIBS TO THIS REMOTE AREA.
IT TURNS OUT THERE WERE A LOT OF
UNSUNG HEROES THAT DAY AT THE
PENTAGON.
>> THERE WERE.
AND THE WAY HE RETELLS THE
STORY.
THE CARE PROVIDERS WERE BEING
TOLD THE PENTAGON DAYCARE WAS
GOING TO CLOSE.
SO THEY WERE KIND OF GETTING
THEIR PINK SLIPS.
AND HE SAID HOW IN THE WORLD DID
YOU GET 100 PLUS INFANTS AND
TODDLERS TO A REMOTE SITE SO
BEAUTIFULLY SECURE WITH, LIKE,
GUARDS PROTECTING THEM A HALF A
MILE A WAY?
AND HE SAID AS SOON AS THE PLANE
HIT, A MARINE, BUT SEVERAL
PEOPLE WHO CAME AND JUST HELPED.
THEY SAID HOW CAN WE HELP?
AND THEY LIFTED THEM AND TOOK
THEM ALL TO A CIRCLING OF THE
WAGONS.
AND THEY WERE IN A PEACEFUL SPOT
IN THE MIDDLE OF CHAOS WHEN HE
FOUND THEM.
>> AND LIEUTENANT, I MEAN,
TRAGICALLY, YOU HAD CLASSMATES
WHO LOST PARENTS THAT DAY.
>> YES, SIR.
I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT HAS ALWAYS STUCK WITH MY
SISTER AND I ABOUT THIS STORY IS
AS MUCH AS OUR STORY IS UNIQUE
IN OUR PROXIMITY TO THE ATTACKS,
IT'S ALSO NOT UNIQUE BECAUSE
IT'S NOT OUR STORY, IT'S A
NATION STORY.
AND RECOGNIZING HOW BLESSED OUR
FAMILY WAS THAT DAY AND ALSO IN
THE 20 YEARS SINCE IS SOMETHING
WE KEEP IN MIND IN OUR SERVICE
IN JUST HOW WE CAN HONOR AND
REMEMBER THE LIVES LOST AND SO
MANY FAMILIES WHO ARE CHANGED.
>> SO SIX WEEKS AFTER 9/11 YOUR
FAMILY GOT TO CELEBRATE YOUR
BELATED, UNDERSTANDABLY, FOURTH
BIRTHDAY, INSTEAD OF A DORA THE
EXPLORER THEME, IT WAS CHANGED
TO, YOU INSISTED ON AN AMERICAN
FLAG-THEMED PARTY.
YOU BECAME KNOWN AS THE LITTLE
PATRIOT.
IS THAT WHAT LED TO YOU TWO
WHERE YOU ARE NOW AS A SECOND
LIEUTENANT?
>> YES, SIR.
IN A SENSE I THINK SO.
I THINK IT WAS LESS ABOUT THE
FLAG AS A PHYSICAL OBJECT AND
MORE THAT I UNDERSTOOD IT TO BE
A SENSE OF COMMUNITY.
IT SEEMED LIKE IN THE WEEKS
AFTER 9/11 EVERYWHERE YOU WENT
THERE WAS AN AMERICAN FLAG ON
DISPLAY.
AND I SAW THAT AS A VISUAL
INDICATION OF PEOPLE
COMMUNICATING THEIR SUPPORT FOR
ONE ANOTHER AND HOW WE WERE
GOING TO COME TOGETHER AND GROW
AND HEAL TOGETHER.
AND SO THAT EXTRINSIC FOCUS IN
SUPPORTING OTHERS IS WHAT
INSPIRED MY SISTER AND I NOW TO
WANT TO SERVE IN A POSITION THAT
WILL BETTER OTHERS AND BE PART
OF SOMETHING BIGGER THAN
OURSELVES.
>> YOUR OTHER DAUGHTER --
>> SHE'S IN HER THIRD YEAR AT
THE NAVAL ACADEMY.
>> AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO CALL ME
SIR, I HAVE NOT EARNED ANYTHING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YOU CAN JUST CALL ME JAKE.
GENERAL, IN THE DAYS AND WEEKS
SINCE 9/11, WE SAW A LOT OF THE
BEST OF THIS COUNTRY, NOT JUST
PATRIOTISM, BUT PEOPLE COMING
TOGETHER, PEOPLE HELPING EACH
OTHER, PEOPLE BEING THERE FOR
EACH OTHER, CELEBRATING FIRST
RESPONDERS.
A SENSE OF UNITY.
IS THAT GONE, DO YOU THINK?
IT FEELS VERY FAR REMOVED FROM
WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
>> IT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
HOPE THAT 9/11 DOES IS TAKES US
BACK TO THAT TIME WHERE THERE IS
THAT SENSE OF UNITY WHERE WE ARE
COMING TOGETHER IN THAT COMMON
PURPOSE.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO BELIEVE THAT
PURVEYOR OF HOPE THAT WE CAN GET
BACK TO THAT.
AND THAT'S A WAY THAT WE CAN
HONOR THOSE THAT PAID THE
ULTIMATE PRICE THAT DAY AND 20
YEARS SINCE.
>> AND WHAT DID THIS TRADITION
OF SERVICE COME ON YOUR FAMILY,
YOUR GENERAL, YOUR HUSBAND'S A
GENERAL.
YOU HAVE A LIEUTENANT.
I MEAN, DO YOU HAVE FAMILY GOING
BACK CENTURIES THAT SERVED?
WHERE DID IT COME FROM?
>> ON HER FATHER'S SIDE AND THE
PATERNAL SIDE, WE DO GO BACK TO
THE CIVIL WAR.
>> ON THE RIGHT SIDE, I HOPE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> AND HIS FATHER, AS A MATTER
OF FACT, WE LOST BOTH PATRIARCHS
THIS COVID SEASON.
BUT HE WAS A WORLD WAR II NAVY
PILOT, ONE OF THE LAST
SINGLE-WINGERS FLEW AIRSHIPS.
AND THEN MY FATHER WHO WE ALSO
LOST THIS YEAR WAS A COAST GUARD
RADIOMAN JUST AFTER WORLD WAR
II.
>> DID YOU LOSE THEM BOTH TO
COVID?
>> MY FATHER-IN-LAW WE DID LOSE
TO COVID IN AN EARLY WAVE IN THE
NURSING HOME.
AND MY FATHER WAS TO
COMPLICATIONS OF ALZHEIMER'S.
>> I'M SO SORRY.
WHAT A HORRIBLE YEAR.
SO, YOU'RE IN THE AIR FORCE,
YOUR YOUNGER SISTER'S IN THE
NAVAL ACADEMY.
BIG QUESTION, WHO IS THE FAMILY
GOING TO ROOT FOR WHEN THE NAVY
PLAYS THE AIR FORCE TOMORROW IN
ANNAPOLIS?
>> I THINK YOU HAVE A BIT OF
BIAS HERE TODAY.
WE'LL OBVIOUSLY SAY AIR FORCE.
BUT MY SISTER AND MY DAD WILL BE
ON THE NAVY SIDE TOMORROW.
>> BUT ARE YOU ABLE TO WATCH A
GAME LIKE THAT IN A HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT?
>> WE'LL TALK AFTERWARDS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> WELL, THANK YOU BOTH SO MUCH
FOR SHARING YOUR STORY.
I'M SO GLAD THAT YOU